look your special gene and if you stop
fighting that force inside you
boom Grayson he will possess the very
power of a guy
if you could team up with anyone else in
the MCU who would it be and why
oh brother hammer brother Hama sole oh
honey I was like who is brother hammer
I say you would go thought yeah I heard
you would go Thor anyone would guy Thor
can't wink but I know what you're
getting that there's Aziz so I'm biased
now really yeah um I'm just thinking
about you just went somewhere I did we
saw that that's just gorgeous all right
yeah um what would your characters do on
their day off oh I just feel like you
have such a pretty Molly peel my skin
off yeah you would I'd be like I'll go
for a little fly yeah I'd love to just
fly around fly around I wouldn't be able
to fly to the moon I don't think I'd
have a little fly around Earth just
check out what's going on okay see the
sights
there's a lot out there there's a lot to
see I'm so young as well it's a whole
new world um I also know do you have
favorites do you have other characters
in the x-men that you are a huge fan of
and you're like oh if I could have a day
acting as their character with their
superheroes the problem is if you're a
fan of them you don't want to see anyone
else play that character it's so true
but I really love Magneto so you want to
play magneto no but I love him actually
it's something that I didn't notice that
you guys had enough power off in a way
could most powerful out there and do you
actually experience having superpowers
as well there is something that I was
thinking a lot about where it's like you
don't have the the soundtrack or like
the Google just hands him a score with
you you don't have CGI you're literally
there using your bodies what is that
like when you have a moment where you're
just like I mean it feels so stupid so
stupid especially when it's like that
scene with Gina magneto we're so loud
and you know with the music on top of it
and the noises of the helicopters and
everything but in reality you're just
going what wasn't me it wasn't me
it was actually sad but Fassbender was
actually in pain during that scene
remember the wires though he was being
hello that's right and it's not the most
comfortable situation but he was like I
mean it was really so I think we all
felt we weren't making that many jokes
that day you know we felt bad for him
yeah so I think that it is painful
because you know for work it's a lot
easier for women mm-hmm
- the bits and pieces in the Hema mm-hmm
there was an intimate moment with you
guys as well where you're kind of
getting a little girl exchanging of
powers let's talk about that honestly
like there's a moment with the yelling
thing again you're just it's like the
direct eye contact thing where you guys
are looking at each other having the
moment without this the CGI and the
effects obviously that must have been
fun and awkward as well
it was I don't find it I think I wonder
if if we had this I think being on movie
so you just get used to those now you're
too awkward things like even you know
before a director says cut there's
always a little bit too long that they
leave where you have to look someone in
the eye for just a bit too long yeah
yeah so I think we were just kind of
used to it mm-hmm
she'll kill us all
but it is um it's quite symbolic the
nature of both of you having the helmet
and placing it on I wanted to know what
was it like sort of almost doing it for
the final find it symbolic as well or am
I just like I didn't think about I
didn't think of it that too much no
that's right my girl is showing sorry
okay yes I learn I though if your
characters had a day off what would you
do we never see down time mutants you
know they were saving the world and
doing their thing get back to the helmet
thing cuz I feel I could dismissed the
question I did think about okay this is
coming out of the box for a long time so
that's what I was thinking it's like
okay here we go again
because you know he was out of the
amazing if Anakin says it's on literally
so downtime I enjoyed there was little
frogs that were in Kenosha by the pond
that we had and I do like amphibians so
I just sort of was watching and sort of
observing the frogs in between takes so
maybe that's what Eric would be doing
would I wouldn't have expected that as
an answer so thank you it's surprising
interview yeah what about Charles Xavier
nothing particularly interesting you
guys watch Downton really / - yes chest
yeah yeah Jess loves a good book
maybe indulges in a wee bit of sci-fi I
think that might be his dirty secret
he's a little bit cheesy sapphire I'm
just talking past I heart reruns reruns
oh how could you not favorite x-men
moment there's been so many movies now
what has been your like ex gonna give it
to your moment where you're just like
this is sick X gon give it here I've
been a lot isn't though yeah there's
been a lot the one we've got to play
opposite party guy was pretty awesome
but then I answered that none previous
thing and then you managed to different
than we did in first class there was
like we had amazing times in first class
crash in the golf buggy that's got a
highlight with our highlight I mean it's
not on film not quietly fellas on gym
you know today somebody would have
definitely caught that on her own
oh yeah flavor subpoena drawn somewhere
he was driving but I actually got
blame for driving that was the beauty of
it you did well because I ended up in
the driver's seat because I flew over
the back seat and you ended up on the
house late 10 feet away when I crashed
oh my gosh they flew me off and then
he'd been hanging out the back and when
I looked up he was sitting in the
driver's position looking at me like
what and he's like Wagner bleeding yeah
then you had a lump on your head yeah
before an accident
yeah of the trilogy of movies you
injured yourself with the golf buggy but
the highlight at that moment was
watching you run away in a in a historic
burglar and a comedy caper burglar can I
walk like a killer please please scatter
it was amazing all right I'm obviously
being a superhero I'm one of the
integral parts especially acting is to
harness the power right uh-huh and I
noticed a little bit time here I was
thinking without the music without the
sound effects without the you know the
CGI how that must feel resonating with
your power just like was there a lot of
those moments where you just like could
look like I'm using powers like I'm
having a pure that was always the go-to
thing always think what would it be like
to be constipated in this scenario yeah
this right now in the air the crunch
moment in the air is the more difficult
to do is it well you know you run the
wires and ORS are even like just on a
plane like I'm alone oh no I mean in
character of course yeah yeah when
you're not grounded and you can't like
yes yeah I don't do this one as much
because I really there's not as much
suffer Danny you're trying not to pull
yours yeah yeah which is it mm-hmm I'm
glad you know it ya know take that flat
water for you
yeah yeah always when in doubt you know
just pull a couple of hairs
that's a friends joke and I know this
yeah I'm stealing it Joey Tribbiani
doesn't the owner twing twing yeah
it's your fault Charles I tried to
protect her
I'm scared
when I lose control that deep zap people
favorite thing there's been so many
x-men movies obviously like the the old
crew and the new crew as I've dubbed it
even though it's not that new anymore
what's your favorite moment that
happened you know you know right
I remember that having an x-men movie
whether you what unit or not uh you mean
okay inside of the movie are like in the
experience of filming it you know what
whatever resonates with you um storm and
Wolverine have this love sequence in
Days of Future past that didn't actually
make it into the movie but in the end
they're like extra scenes or whatever
there's a moment where they're like oh
Stormin who Wolverine so like if Hugh
Jackman wanted to reprise his role and
you can see what happens on camera for
the sake of chick character just like a
quick Peck I would be fine with honestly
let me smell his hair less is more it
smells good I bet it is really perfect
favorite favorite favorite moment
favorite scene favorite o experience
like ever I like in the first one when
the senator melts he's like water and
he's like we became what a jellyfish
yeah he's like a jellyfish it's it's
incredible I think about that at least
once a month
yeah me too yeah yeah he look like that
fish that you find like really deep in
the ocean the white and the sad nose
yeah I you get some yeah if you could
team up with any other hero in the MCU
who would it be I have my favorite
moments from this film it happens at the
end of the film so I can't okay you need
to go see it because it's yeah I want to
team up with group okay right
Simon Groot I am Groot I am store I
think every great our conversations
would be really once I could water him
all the time
topic guys talk about I don't want to
have favor to you but I have a favorite
what I team up with anyone anyone yeah
yeah this daddy issue thing but he feels
it a visceral level yeah it's hard to
carry on what are you gonna have and see
if you run into Michael in the whole is
it like do you stare them down a little
bit and you like anytime buddy what's up
dude use the phone maybe let's go hang
out girl dies she's still June we can
still help her sometimes you want to
believe people as something that they
are not
now the time he knows who they are it's
too late I keep calling them the new
crew and then actually they're not new
anymore at all it's been almost ten
years now yeah uh-huh so are you
thinking about the next step early you
know I certainly in making us like I
said I imagined that this was the
culmination of this cycle of x-men
storytelling because this x-men first
class cast came together as a family
they were strangers as characters in
x-men first class they came together
over these various movies and in this
one they're sort of torn apart and
challenged like they never have been
before and lose people in their midst
and then ultimately come back together
and so it felt like if you've seen any
of the x-men movies and especially if
you've seen any of the x-men first class
cast movies you sort of need to see this
one to sort of tie it off it's like the
last episode of your favorite show
having said that I'm sure they'll be
feature x-men movies I just wasn't
thinking about them because I was so
focused on this one and telling this one
in a way that felt complete like it
completed the journey of nine years of
storytelling for the first-class cast in
really twenty years of storytelling for
all of the x-men movies let's play
favorites
oh can I do your children who are they
who are your favorites my favorite
characters yeah x-men yes favorite x-men
yeah I know um you know growing up
reading the comic magneto was always
always my favorite character um I just
love the complexity of a villain who has
such a sympathetic backstory and who has
you know is just a badass and and so
magneto was always my favorite character
in the comics and I've loved the way
that he and Michael have played him in
the films - my favorite Michael
Fassbender is a pissed off Michael
Fassbender I said I mean what's so great
about a pissed-off Michael Fassbender is
like it he does it with like so much in
nuance you know like he doesn't need to
yell he doesn't need to attack like kids
in his eyes he has the most expressive
eyes as an actor and of something I was
really trying to explore in this film
and something that Michael and I talked
about a lot is like he he can do so much
with so little and that's you know true
for many of the best actors so he's my
favorite
you